Alright, kids, today we're going
to read the biography
of Nick Saban.
Oo, it starts of with a quote
from Nick Saban, himself.
"Football is not Hamlet.
It's not tragedy.
It should be fun."
Tell it to your face.
Saban, who was then the head
coach of the Dolphins
had publicly denied any interest
in the Alabama job
over and over and over.
Well, guess I can
close the book.
There's no way
he's going to Alabama.
A man is only as good
as his word.
Keep reading!
Saban knew how it would look
if he left the Dolphins
after just two seasons.
He would be called a liar,
a failure and a quitter.
Say it with me, kids:
(all together)
A liar, a failure and a quitter.
But the decision
wasn't his alone.
Yes, it was. Nobody gives a
(bleep) what your wife thinks.
Wayne Huizenga was paying you
millions of dollars.
You don't even give a (bleep)
about your wife.
You know why she wanted out?
She felt ugly in Miami.
If you want to feel smart,
sexy and special,
you surround yourself
with thousands of
toothless townies in Tuscaloosa.
She also believed that
a college town
was a much healthier place
to raise their two children.
Didn't his daughter, Kristen,
almost murder someone
with her bare hands?
Yes. Yes, she did.
Saban says, "In the NFL,
you were penalized for success."
What success?
Exactly!
The only thing that's smaller
than his Hitler 'stache
is Nick Saban's dick.
That overinflated football fan
is Stingray
and he eats, sleeps, eats
and breathes Mississippi State.
Stingray got internet famous
for hooting
and hollering about
one of the worst teams
in one of
the most top-heavy,
overrated conferences
of all-time, the SEC.
The Southeastern Conference,
or KKK for short.
It's like the NFL
for garbage states too poor
to support a pro team.
If you're not sure which teams
are part of the SEC,
google most uneducated states,
or states with the highest rate
of uninsured adults,
or hardest places
to get an abortion.
The only thing the SEC hates
more than gay marriage
is the forward pass.
If it weren't for
college football,
SEC fans would never know
college existed.
Someone needs to tell
these simpletons
they've got three sets
of tigers, two sets of bulldogs,
and one team named
after a woman's period.
Alright, Stingray,
I got one more surprise
for you before the big game.
The Bulldogs are going to let me
return a kickoff?
No! I got rid of the South's
most hateful statue.
You tore down Robert E. Lee?
Hell no!
I tore down Nick Saban's statue
over in Tuscaloosa.
No five-foot tall man
deserves a statue.
What'd you do with it?
I melted it down, sculpted it
into a real Southern hero.
There she is, Stingray,
in all her majesty.
You were born to be bronzed.
It's no secret that I think
Nick Saban is a horrible human,
and it doesn't help
that he just hired
that whiny, arrogant,
beautiful Lane Kiffin.
So, imagine my delight
when I found out Lane
and his lovely wife
have a public access show.
Welcome back.
You're on triple K.
What's your question?
Hey, Lane, just wondering
if it's natural talent
or if you guys practice fumbling
all the (bleep) time,
you stupid piece of (bleep).
Alright, I'm going to go jizz
inside your tramp of a wi-
Alright, no pain, no Lane.
Next caller.
I love what you've done
to open up the offense,
to give the Tide and identity
as a passing team.
I was wondering what
Nick Saban's oatmeal cream
pies taste like when
he (bleep) them in your mouth,
you (bleep) coward!
War Eagle, you pussy! You look-
Maybe we start screening
some of these calls.
I'd like to apologize
to our viewers.
Second down. Let's try again.
Long time caller, first time
listener, big USC fan.
I hope you die of AIDS,
you overpaid pussy.
We have got to get
a longer cord next season.
Who am I kidding? We're not
going to be here next year.
Next caller.
What was it like being
the last regret
in Al Davis' 50-year career
full of (bleep)-ups?
I'll take your answer
off the air, you
(bleep)-licking (bleep) for
brains.
Two-part question.
Now that you're down
South,
you going to divorce your wife
so you can start
(bleep) farm animals?
If you do divorce your wife,
you think she'll be able
to handle my big fat (bleep)
after all those years
of your pencil dick?
When are you going to be
head coach again, sweetie?
Not now, my love.
Next caller.
Oh, nice trophy case,
you un-winning (bleep).
Look how goddamn empty
that thing is.
Where you going to fail
upwards next?
I got a question about
the no-huddle offense.
Okay, this one I should
be able to handle.
Why do you think you prefer
the hurry up, but every time
I (bleep) your smoking hot wife
in the ass,
she begs me to slow down?
I'm pretty sure
that was Urban Meyer.
Next caller.
Are you going to be
the next coordinator
to start molesting children?
Just kidding, I know you are,
you (bleep)
(bleep)-face
pedophile.
People really don't like you.
Next caller.
Bama fans are
all sister-(bleep) retards
Goddammit!
Hope you all die in a-
Next caller.
Keep it clean, and don't say
a word about my wife.
Nice tits, bitch.
Nice pleated Dockers, you prick.
Shut up!
Oh, yeah, look at you.
Hit the button.
-Shut...
-Oh, yeah.
...your face.
Shut...
Oh, yeah, that's going to work,
idiot.
(mocking)
I don't know how to work phones.
Shut up.
(mocking)
I'm Lane Kiffin.
Hey, do you wear that visor
when you (bleep) your dad?
...have a long feud
with Nick Saban.
Now as an Auburn alum,
do you have a message for him?
War Eagle.
War Eagle, is that fun to yell?
It is.
Were you at Auburn when
those inbred (bleep)
over at Alabama
poisoned your tree?
I was.
How did that make you feel?
I mean 'Bama sucks.
'Bamers are 'Bamers.
Was that worse than a school
shooting do you think?
The tree?
No?
Ew.
I think you answered it.